so with me is Christoph heuskin chairman
of the Munich security conference and
following this NATO Summit looking uh
Christoph at the new strategic Compass
there's some strong language there
talking about Russia as the most direct
and and significant enemy and threat to
Nato security so do you think member
states understand the message it takes a
thorough rethink for many of them Italy
France Germany even
yes but look at the reality look at what
is happening on the ground so what the
NATO strategic concept says reflects the
reality of the ground and NATO has to
adapt this strategy and I think this is
the right response now we have Russia as
an enemy Russia as a country that
violates international law Russia that
is committing war crimes and NATO has to
respond to this and this new strategic
concept is the right response the right
response of course also means that
supporting Ukraine president zielinski
has sent another message asking for more
support Russia is reacting to the summit
by bombing the east of the country more
intensely than in weeks did we deliver
enough weapons did we do it quickly
enough and do we really need to step up
now
well it you know it's not worth to look
look back what could have been done
faster
fact is that Ukraine is on the defensive
right now but these Ukrainian soldiers
what the military do is tremendous when
they are when they're defending their
Homeland but they're also defending us
they're defending
um the those countries that share the
same values and therefore we have to
support them we are supporting them in
many respects we take a lot of refugees
we support them economically we give
them budget aid but we also have to give
Hardware we have to support them
militarily they're the um the weapons
that have been delivered right now I
think they are very good and it's it's
good that it's done but we have to do
more we have for instance to give them
the moderate tanks that are ready with
the with industry and I think we should
deliver them so deliver thanks you mean
Germany should change its town they've
been reluctant to do this didn't want to
talk about it so that was one of the
sort of nasty areas not not really
spoken about should the chancellor go
forward there well let's go back to the
to the 23rd of February at this stage
Germany said we will not close northrim
2 will not do Swift we'll not send any
weapons and then Russia invaded and
Chancellor Schultz had the famous Titan
vendor speech and you know things have
changed and we see that this this war is
continuing and I think we we also have
to continue to adapt our position to the
situation and the situation is such that
Ukraine needs its support we see that
Russia has has problems to get all the
you know all the weapons there they have
moral problems and in this moment to
support Ukraine to to actually defend
their country I think this is for us
very important there shouldn't be a
question we have to go all in in those
weapons that are um that we can send and
that we don't need for you know the core
of Our National Defense many are
expecting and you are amongst them a
long War what does it mean the winter
next year and can we sustain uh the the
togetherness can we sustain NATO as a
union as that's the main message here we
are we're sticking together this is a
key question no Putin doesn't have any
national opposition there is no free
media he is throwing in lots of soldiers
young people who don't even know why
they are where they are and getting
killed Putin is a dictator and we have
to confront him and he believes that we
are not able to he believes that you
know we are our societies are decadent
we are not ready to um you know pay a
certain price for the freedom of Ukraine
and we have to understand this is our
freedom and we have to support them this
is a question of leadership I think this
is a question also
um of um you know our people being ready
to pay a price for the freedom of of
Ukraine which is their own freedom but I
think when you when you discuss it with
the people and you explain it you can do
it and I think Putin will not win we
will we will win
of course the famous Klitschko brothers
from a cave where in the fringes of the
summit and they talked to journalists
and said make no mistake they're coming
for you Russia they're coming for you
next so do you think we're sufficiently
afraid has a population of Europe an
outfits politicians understood the
message
well we see that Putin has violated all
International treaties um the U.N
Charter the
um he has the the osce founding act he
has violated the Minsk agreements he has
even violated the so-called Budapest
memorandum where
um Ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons
because Russia promised them their
territorial Integrity that they would
not attack them and put in
um light Putin broke every International
treaty and so we have to be ready that
the guy has no Scruples therefore we
have to we have to be worried we have to
do our job and you know we see the
changes we see the changes now in
defense we see changes also
um in in energy and we have to continue
to do that and we have to prove that we
have the resilience
thank you very much my pleasure thank
you